-Welcome back Nicole Kidman.
You look gorgeous.
Welcome back to the show.
And thank you for being here and
thank you for playing that --
-Ha!
-I'm sorry, that horrible --
-I'll never forgive you.
-That was frightening, right?
-Whew!
Yes, that was terrifying.
-But that's interesting
because I know for a fact you're
not really afraid of things.
-I'm not, but for some reason,
you got me all amped up, then...
You were great, 'cause you
terrified me when you started.
-You guys were
absolutely fantastic.
-Gasping!
But that was kinda frightening.
What was that thing, by the way?
-No one knows what that was.
-Oh!
-No one even told us.
But nothing --
-Some sort of eel.
-Last time you were on,
I think I brought out --
-You don't want to talk
about the eel.
-I just don't know what it is.
-You're like, "Move off it."
-I moved off it.
I actually started sweating
from that game.
-Yeah, I can see!
-Scares me so much.
Like, you can see how tough.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, I'm not really
the toughest.
Yeah, I was like --
No, I couldn't even touch.
That was gross.
-I'm not doing that again.
No, never doing that again. No.
But let's just --
I want to talk to you.
I'm so happy you're here,
'cause you were nice enough
to Zoom into our show when
we were on during the pandemic,
and thank you,
I appreciate that.
-Just trying to get my suit
to sit properly.
-You look gorgeous, by the way.
Fantastic.
-No, it is...Anyway.
-Yeah. Okay.
-Don't worry about me.
-I'm not worried --
I am worried.
I have to worry about you.
Yeah, I care about it you.
-Oh, thank you.
-You're here in new York.
-Came in just for you.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-Not really.
-Come on, that's what -- What?!
[ Laughter ]
That's a lie.
-Little bit, little bit for you.
-Yeah, a little bit.
-Is Christmas up
in your house yet?
Are you all ready
for the holidays?
-Yes, we are all ready
and we are celebrating
and we've got lights
and festivities
and eggnog and...
-Where will you be celebrating?
-Australia.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, but we sort of...
We're in Nashville and then
Keith is actually in Australia
and we're heading out there
after I've done the premiere.
-Keith's going on tour, right?
Giant world tour.
-Yes, he's on this --
Yes. He's fantastic.
-That's a giant deal.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-I saw a couple of videos
where you were with Keith.
You were singing -- you sung
background in a couple things.
Do you do that on tour?
-No, I didn't.
-Yeah, you did.
-No.
-Definitely.
-I never did.
-What are you talking about?
[ Laughter ]
-I saw you.
I saw you sing background.
-I wasn't sing-- What?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, Keith came out and then
you came and sang background.
It was for a charity thing.
Yeah.
-Hm. I don't remember that.
[ Laughs ]
-What are you talking about?
You don't sing with --
-What is this?
-No, it's not on there, but --
It's not on there, but you --
What are you talking about?
-I did not.
Anyway, yeah.
-You don't sing with your --
-Look, I'll let you
save face with that.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't sing with him when --
at all?
-No.
-How do you not sing
with your husband?
He's Keith Urban!
-Oh.
Well, I mean, I hum
in the background, but --
-There you go!
See?
Now it comes out, Your Honor!
Your Honor, does she hum
in the background?
I saw you in the background
singing --
oh, sorry -- humming.
I'm sorry. Wow.
-I don't remember singing.
What are you talking about?
But anyway. I'll go with it.
I'll go with it.
-You grill me every time.
-You come out and you grill me.
Oh, you know, I have --
-'Cause you're fun.
-I have holiday questions.
Thank you. And you are, too.
I have holiday questions
I want to ask you,
just a speed round
of holiday questions.
Ready for this?
-Nobody told me
about this part of it.
What?
-Favorite holiday song?
-Nah. Um...
[ Laughter ]
-You're so difficult.
-[ Gasps ]
Did you call me difficult?
[ Laughter ]
-You know I'm saying that
jokingly.
You're the most non-difficult --
-Don't.
Well, I have a lot of favorite
holiday songs.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Good answer.
-My husband wrote a song called
"I'll Be Your Santa Tonight,"
which is pretty good.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-"I'll Be Your Santa Tonight."
-That's good.
Favorite holiday movie?
-Hmm.
-"Wonderful Life"?
-Okay. I'll go with that.
And "Elf."
-Oh, "Elf"'s great.
-A little "Elf."
-Yeah, I love "Elf," yeah.
Yeah, I like "Elf," too.
-A little "Elf."
-Favorite holiday pie?
-Hmm.
Uh...pumpkin.
-Pumpkin pie.
I love pumpkin pie.
-Yeah?
-I love pumpkin pie.
-A little apple pie,
bit of cream.
-Yeah, exactly.
Real tree or fake tree?
-Got anything better
on this list?
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't write this.
I don't know if this list --
-Is this really gonna
make the show?
-Nah.
-No?!
-No, it's not gonna
make the show.
-Oh, I'll ask you.
[ Laughter ]
Turkey or ham?
-Turkey or ham?
I don't even know
what that means.
Probably turkey. I don't know.
These questions are terrible.
-Kiss under the mistletoe?
-I mean...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah, sure.
Of course. [ Laughing ]
Anyway.
-Do you like eggnog?
-I'll tell you what I tried.
Have you ever tried coquito?
-Whoo!
-Yeah!
-No, but it sounds like
my kind of thing.
-Coquito is
a Puerto Rican eggnog.
And it is off-the-charts
delicious.
I like eggnog, but then someone
introduced me to coquito.
-What is in coquito?
-It's a mystery.
And it's always, like,
someone's mom makes it
and they give it to you
in, like, an old --
-Does anybody here know coquito?
[ Audience cheers ]
-Oh! Great.
-Am I close?
Like, someone's mom makes it
and they give it to you
as a present.
And it has coconut in it
and rum, right?
-Ooh.
-What else?
He just keeps saying yeah.
What?
-Coconut milk, rum,
and a lot of secret stuff.
-Yeah, I like that.
-You can do that?
Alright, so you like that?
-Yeah.
-Next time we can get
a little coquito
and try that together.
-Okay.
-Any more questions for me?
Do you want to sit here?
-No.
-Alright.
There's nothing --
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
Just tear them up!
Okay. Thank you.
I'll get rid of that.
That was a bad idea.
Alright.
I'm excited to talk to you
about "Being the Ricardos."
You're getting rave reviews
on this.
Was there ever any...
Were you hesitant at all
to not take this part?
Like, "I'm not sure
if I want to do this"?
-Yeah, I was.
No, initially, I was like...
Aaron Sorkin, which you would
know Aaron Sorkin, right?
-Love Aaron Sorkin.
-Ohh!
Aaron Sorkin,
who wrote the screenplay
and directed the film,
said to me,
"Would you be interested
in doing this?"
And we Zoomed and I was like,
"Yes, I would you love to do
anything with you."
I read it and was just
completely captivated.
It's an incredible story.
-I want to talk more
about the movie
and how you got into character
as Lucille Ball.
More with Nicole Kidman
when we come back.